today's topic China now during this
whole pandemic I've seen so much talk
about China and some people are like
putting blame on China some people feel
it's unacceptable I have to ask
yourselves when are we going to have
this real discussion not about the
Chinese people about the Chinese
government that's not the people there's
a difference you have to me the
difference though the media here makes
it sound like you cannot criticize China
whatsoever
if you do you're somehow bigoted and all
this other stuff anti-government as a
government the governmental response
from China to this virus has been one of
the big reasons that it spreads so much
not only the studies showcasing that but
the very own Chinese people have taken
to their media platforms to express
their outrage of how the Chinese
government has handled it so if the
Chinese people are upset why is it so
strange for foreign governments and for
foreigners to be also upset with their
response if you don't remember early on
when this happened that government
denied the existence of the virus they
made everyone think they were crazy they
silenced people they allegedly made
people disappear a medical center in the
epicenter of the virus outbreak under
stress short on supplies overwhelmed
with patients the video is from chuncho
a lawyer who made the risky choice to
become a citizen journalist and defy
government efforts to control
information in front of me is the virus
and behind me is the legal and
administrative power of China as long as
I live in this city
I will continue to report well I only
report what I see what I hear I'm not
even scared of death you think I'm
afraid of the Communist Party
no Chern is gone he disappeared last
week and has not responded to messages
so far authorities would only say he is
quote under control
Amnesty International say he's been
forcibly quarantined
and he's not the only one to pay the
price for defying state authority the
blogger Fang Binh took this video from a
hospital in Wu it seems to show body
bags then he received a menacing knock
on his door
you got you got 5 UD ha yeah let me take
that 5 you back Wow
do you dance another nice email twenties
slim to that boo you don't want in Santa
were your father Babu haha fine had been
posting videos daily proof that he was
free those uploads stopped on Monday and
he's been unreachable by phone fueling
speculation of his arrest when Lee when
Lang a doctor in Wuhan warned of the
virus in December
authorities accused him and several
others of severely disturbing the social
order right four months four months when
people could have been taking this more
seriously and could have been preparing
right
they hid what was going on in Taiwan the
alarm bells started ringing early long
before Canada and others reacted how a
people so close to the epicenter could
have avoided the worst so far no it's
not over and we are not reaching the
peak investigators confirmed at least 41
people are sick with the mysterious new
virus Joseph Wu explains when suspicious
cases popped up in China labeled as
pneumonia Taiwan deployed a task force
to investigate first hand when they
returned they told the key health
officials the China was trying to hide
something in therefore we got nervous
then they went under martial law they
try to span a whole bunch of you know
fake conspiracies that America didn't
all this other stuff so there is a
responsibility on that government there
are negligence spread this I'm not
talking about the people I'm not saying
Chinese people are culpable for what's
happening all right I don't condone any
of the terrible things that are
happening to agents all over the world
as a result of some kind of bigoted
movement by people who want to pit blame
the
it's not their fault that's not what I'm
saying put their government should be
held accountable and I don't know why
people are so quick to tape for this
government I understand that they have
huge lobbying power that they have their
money and everything it's not even
obvious even the money it's maybe it's
part of the money yes part of it is the
money there's another part it is people
don't want to be they don't want to
sound calling it the China virus sounds
because you when you target to China you
don't want to be you you don't want to
target the Chinese people you don't want
to but you have to be able to make the
separation what that we're doing right
now we're not blaming the people we're
blaming the government as a matter of
fact like you said before the people
that you think you're blaming they have
been blaming the government therefore
you know I definitely agree that's
probably a part of it but also we have
to also admit who's part of is just
China's money so you gotta you you
better protect your neck cuz you know
when clearly not enough quit go if you
feel the symptoms go check inspect the
back it's true it's true there's a
method to this [ __ ] look at the NBA
players and really players like now
you'll never tell me to shut up and
dribble in China's like shut up and
dribbling
yes we can Obama real quick and they're
lobbying powers immense they can silence
anybody but it just it blows my mind
that people are so quick to want to
defend this oppressive regime don't keep
in mind it still has a whole bunch of
Muslims in concentrations right now in
China yeah it is you have concentration
for Muslims yeah
it's an oppressive regime so many humans
right your rights violation you see what
they were doing the Hong Kong and all
you know I remember a couple months back
everyone's like Hong Kong we got support
we got support and now this happens
and they're still engaging in a lot of
the same tactics and all of a sudden you
guys want to defend them I don't
understand cuz they don't want to look
bigoted listen China is clearly
weaponizing identity politics against us
they've put out reports saying oh if you
say this kind of stuff you're Rossi's
and all this other stuff I'm like calm
down okay
couldn't be
wrong not everything that we'd not all
Christian that you receive as a result
of your race mm-hmm
listen if you're a man and you have HIV
and you lie to everybody about having
HIV and then you spread it that's a
crime you should be held accountable how
is this any different how is it how is
it I don't see it wait nope even the
Chinese people are like yo you got to
disclose your HIV status so how are we
wrong I don't get that and now they have
all these reports about how they got
zero new cases I don't believe a single
word that comes out of Chinese
government media not a single one they
bring a lot of information and Internet
so this is like a Twilight Zone there
was one night it's mild North Korea it's
North Korea diet so let's loot in free
North Korea if you will North Korea zero
[Laughter]
cholesterol free North Korea here's your
fortune cookie your future don't look
[Laughter]
like good wine cowboy they're painting
this narrative so that they don't have
to pay after this what they should
they've messed up
they've cost people their lives they
have cost economies their money they
should 100% be held liable further
involvement in this it doesn't mean that
we couldn't have done better doesn't
mean that other response shouldn't have
been better what well they have been
extremely negligent in this it is what
it is I don't care if Trump agrees with
this sentiment I don't care if he's the
one saying it my problem is not with who
says it I don't care if orange I don't
care about that what is the truth what
is right everyone wants to get mad at
him because he said it boom CNN been
saying the virus they've been saying
everybody been saying been think it was
and then he says that everyone's like
that's what calm down this is where we
stand on this we want to hear what you
guys think what do you think about
China's involvement what do you think
about the criticism levy towards them
and the fact that everyone is Rossi's if
they say anything about this we want to
want to hear your thoughts so let us
know in the comments below
man clay ain't none
[Music]
in Taiwan the alarm bells started
ringing early long before Canada and
others reacted they handled it really
well they did they check your
temperature everywhere they as people I
used to wear a mask back in January the
islands war against was already
mobilized we tried to stop the flights
from China very young when the case in
England seems to be a coin out of hand
we stopped the export of masks and then
we start rationing and then we increase
our production Taiwan's Foreign Minister
is in demand taking panic calls from
other countries asking how Taiwan did it
I don't think Canada is as late as the
United States as we see the case is
shooting up very rapidly we do worry
about the United States how a people so
close to the epicenter could have
avoided the worst so far no it's not
over